demonstrationsverbote kontakt verboten
selbst im privaten 3g 2g in dieser
corona krise gibt seit zwei jahren
heftige eingriffe in unsere freiheiten
immer noch wir sprechen über diese
freiheits eingriffe hinterfragen sie
denn einige dieser maßnahmen bleiben
einfach absurd darüber sprechen wir
jetzt mit nicole riese sie wollte
demonstrieren und durfte das nicht hier
in berlin schönen guten tag frau reese
ihre demo verboten wofür oder wogegen
wollten sie auf die straße gehen
erstmal guten morgen ja wir wollten
friedlich zusammen es ist unser hashtag
wir wollten friedlich zusammen für eine
freie impfentscheidung für offene
schulen und für und die unsere
solidarität für die pflege und blaulicht
berufe und tun und diese demonstrationen
wurde verboten welche gründe wurden da
genannt und wie groß ist ihr verständnis
oder ihr unverständnis dafür
ja wir wurden letztendlich auch verdacht
verboten uns wurde gesagt ja wir
erkennen an dass ihr eine gruppe aus der
mitte der gesellschaft sein aber wir
würden ja trotzdem mit unserer kritik
die negative von anderen gruppen und
querdenkern bedienen und man befürchtete
dass die querdenker unsere demonstration
kaufen würden und wir nicht in der lage
sein die hygiene auflagen durchzusetzen
fühlen sie sich im moment in ihrer
freiheit also eingeschränkt
ja durchaus fühle ich mich in meiner
freiheit
eingeschränkt ich vor allem gemeinden
demonstrationsrecht wenn ich sozusagen
eine demonstration auch verdacht
verbiete
ohne dass mir selber ein vorwurf gemacht
wird das kann ja immer passieren dass
würde letztendlich dazu führen dass von
ihrem demonstrationsrecht nicht mehr
viel übrig bleibt wir haben ja auch
schon öfter miteinander gesprochen ihr
kernthema sie machen sich für familien
stark für kinder die in dieser pandemie
ja besonders leiden wie sehr können sie
das argument verstehen die sorge
verstehen dass sich auch in ihrer
demonstration menschen gewaltbereite
menschen mischen oder querdenker mission
die dann wirklich zur gefahr werden
können also wie sehr es ihn überhaupt
die möglichkeit gegeben noch frei zu
demonstrieren und wie sehr können sie
sich von diesen gruppen überhaupt noch
abgrenzen dann also wir können uns
abgrenzen weil wir aus der mitte der
gesellschaft kommen ich glaube übrigens
dass auf den meisten demonstrationen
deutschlandweit überwiegend menschen aus
der mitte der gesellschaft sind ich habe
gerade heute gelesen berliner zeitung
100000 menschen haben demonstriert ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es sich
dabei um 100000 gewaltbereite
rechtsradikale an das müssen menschen
aus der mitte der gesellschaft sein und
die haben das recht demonstrieren und ja
wir möchten nicht mit nazis mit
marschieren wenn wir das mitbekommen
würden wir sofort an die polizei wenden
oder die demonstration auflösen wir
haben auch im vornherein gesagt wir
halten uns an die hygiene auflagen
um legal demonstrieren zu dürfen
das kann ich verstehen dass da sorgen
bestehen aber ich erwarte von der presse
und auch von der politik dass eben
neutralem objektiv berichtet wird und
nicht einfach pauschal jeder demo
teilnehmer als corona leute dahin
gestellt wird wir haben oder viele von
uns haben bestimmte maßnahmen im blick
die wir nicht gut finden aber wir
leuchten ja nicht ganz pauschal und ich
denke auch dass die meisten eben nicht
jetzt zeigen sie natürlich gerade die
bilder aber die meisten bilder sind sehr
friedliche bilder ich will nicht sagen
dass es eben keine keine gewalt gibt
aber
das ist nicht die mehrheit in der tat
frau reese vielen dank für das gespräch
genau darüber wollten wir ja auch mit
ihnen sprechen über ihre ganz
persönliche freiheitseinschränkung ihre
demonstration von vor allen dingen
müttern die verboten wurde hier in
berlin danke für das gespräch eine demo
die verboten wurde unter freiem himmel
von menschen die sagen sie halten sich
an alle auflagen über solche
freiheitseinschränkung müssen wir reden
nach zwei jahren corona krise was ist
dann noch gerechtfertigt was nicht was
ist völlig überzogen unsere reporter die
haben sich auf die suche gemacht nach
genau solchen beispielen nach absurden
und nach unverschämten freiheits
einschränkungen und wir schalten dazu
nach leipzig nach hamburg nach münchen
zuerst nach leipzig zu unserer bild
reporterin jacqueline ritscher hat wo
stehst du und was genau ist bei dir die
große die absurde die flechten verstehen
jetzt anschließen
ich stehe in der leipziger mädler
passage vor einem der berühmtesten
restaurants der welt der auerbachs
keller ist über 500 jahre alt an guten
tagen kommen hier seit über zweitausend
gäste und essen im jahr ungefähr 36.000
rouladen das muss man sich mal
vorstellen
gestern für diesen interview mit dem
betreiber renner stoffregen die
situation ist eine ganz andere eine
fahne von einer triumphalen rückkehr von
publikum kann im moment keine rede sein
ganz im gegenteil das restaurant seit
anfang des jahres komplett ist der
betrieb hat sich einfach nicht mehr
gelohnt man muss sich das vorstellen
seit 19 dezember sind die korona
maßnahmen hier in sachsen derartig
restriktiv das restaurant ist nur von 6
bis 20 uhr öffnen können jeglicher
touristischer betriebes untersagt und so
ein weltberühmtes restaurant wie
auerbachs keller das im prinzip von der
tradition lebt von goethes haus das
jeder kennt ist natürlich von tourismus
angewiesen das ist doch ganz klar das
sommergeschäft kann das auch nicht
retten das zeigt euch das jetzt mal hier
ich für euch mal hin der große saal fast
450 leute es gibt keine terrasse das
sommergeschäft war also im prinzip nicht
unbedingt das große ding im dezember hat
sich gelohnt aber trotzdem durch
abstandsregeln geimpft und genesene
nachweis fiel der umsatz machte mit der
chef auf 20 prozent des vor corinna
niveaus zurück und das wird davon auf
dauer nicht leben kann kann sich jeder
denken 91 mitarbeiter wieder in
kurzarbeit wieder frustration wieder
schlechte stimmung traurige gesichter
einfach die kraft geht langsam aus nun
hoffen die sächsischen gastronom auf die
nächste kabinetts corona runde am 7
januar aber ganz ehrlich michael
kretschmer hat die maßnahme gestern in
einer video-konferenz wieder verteilt
ist die hoffnung dass sich etwas ändert
dass endlich wie herr stoffregen aussagt
dass die öffnungszeiten auf 22 um
mindesten müssen um das geschäft
einigermaßen rentabel zu machen die
hoffnung sind gering also
traditionsnamen am rande der existenz in
leipzig vielen dank der wir schauen
weiter zu thomas uber nach münchen
thomas wo bist du unterwegs welche
freiheitseinschränkung erscheint dort in
bayern besonders absurd oder besonders
schmerzhaft
kinder jetzt in den bussen nicht mehr
fahren dürfen ohne ohne gm zusammen
genießen oder einen test zu machen das
galt vorher nicht da konnten die kinder
wer ideen fehlen die wusste so benutzten
zu ihren freunden fahren
wo man besuchen etc aber das ist eben
nicht mehr und noch eine besonderheit
kommt am 10 januar kommt der nächste
krone haben wir in bayern da müssten die
kita kinder die sind gerade mal die das
erste lebensjahr vollendet haben wir
müssen am pool tests teilnehmen oder
mütter müssen einen nachweis bringen
dass die kinder geimpft sind oder dass
die kinder
negativen tesco hat ist haben der
heftige
freiheitseinschränkung immer noch nach
mehr als zwei jahren corona krise in
ganz deutschland auch in hamburg bei
charly walter charlie worüber regen sich
die hamburger aktuell auf hamburg er
besonders streng wie wir seit gestern
wieder wissen mit 2g plus flächendeckend
in hamburg
aus hamburg hier in einer der besten
unis in deutschland wird fast 50.000
menschen studieren da gilt seit vier
wochen die regel und sind jetzt hier in
der bibliothek der kunstgeschichte zum
beispiel da darf man nur rein wenn man
geben oder genießen ist ich habe hier
selber vor einigen jahren studiert da
war es wie an allen in deutschland
man konnte einfach so in jedes gebäude
jede bibliothek in jedem jahr ein damit
ist jetzt muss man braucht eben ein
nachweis es soll für alle die nicht gibt
sind ersatz angeboten die nicht näher
definiert sind und das passt in der tat
in der thema das in hamburg die regeln
grundsätzlich r streng waren und sind
seit anfang der pandemie du hast es ja
schon erwähnt seit oder ab montag gilt
dann zwei gibt fluten in allen fast
allen einrichten wer dann ins restaurant
isst oder ins schwimmbad oder ins
theater ins museum da reicht es nicht
mehr dass man die ems oder genießen ist
man braucht es zusätzlich noch einen
negativen
schnelltests ausnahmen gibt es dann nur
für kinder und für bewusste
er ist also die situation in hamburg
eine kleine zusammenfassung ein blick
ins land nach leipzig nach münchen nach
hamburg von unseren reporterinnen
reportern vielen herzlichen dank
er feiere corona grenze patricia immer
noch genau an wie wir es gerade gehört
und gesehen haben heftige absurde
teilweise unverschämte
freiheitseinschränkung darüber sprechen
wir und hinterfragen auch diese
maßnahmen natürlich bei uns im studio
mit unserem politik reporter sebastian
geisler also zwei jahre aus
demokratischer sicht aus sicht unserer
bürger von uns aus unserer sicht so wie
gerechtfertigt hältst du noch all diese
freiheitseinschränkung nach so langer
zeit also ich muss sagen ich bin
natürlich kein verfassungsrechtler aber
wir haben ja einige beispiele hier schon
gesehen also wenn man sagt kinder und
jugendliche ab 14 warum eigentlich auf
14 dürfen nachmittags dieselben freunde
nicht mehr treffend privat die sie
morgens in der schule getroffen haben
oder mit denen sie beim mannschaftssport
in derselben umkleide waren dann muss
ich sagen das ist eine maßnahme die so
offensichtlich aus meiner sicht nicht in
ordnung geht da bin ich sehr gespannt ob
das nicht möglicherweise auch in kürze
schon von einem gericht kassiert werden
wird eine solche maßnahme das halte ich
für eine sinnlose
freiheitseinschränkung demo verbote ein
riesenthema er muss man sagen also wenn
eltern demonstrieren gegen
schulschließungen dann ist das etwas was
eigentlich erstmal in ordnung ist es
reicht da auch aus
verfassungsrechtlicher sicht offenbar
nicht aus zu sagen wir sind aber in
sorge wegen des infektions geschehens
sondern der staat muss konkret beweisen
sagt uns auch verfassungsrechtler josef
lindner heute in bild das von einer
demonstration eine konkrete
gefährdungslage ausgeht wenn er das
nicht kann dann ist die demo an sich
auch in ordnung wird es diese zum
beispiel die wir gerade gesehen haben
sehr schwer zu vermitteln sein dass sie
eine gefährdung dargestellt hat dass sie
möglicherweise dass ihr gewalt
unterstellt wird all das ist ja nicht
geschehen sie wollte halt tatsächlich
vor allen dingen gegen schulschließungen
vor allen dingen für die kinder für die
jugend für deren interessen auf die
straße gehen gerade diese ist nun ganz
sicher auch keine gewaltbereite
extremisten oder so wenn das so wäre der
solche fälle gibt es ja dann ist es in
ordnung auch eine demonstration zu
untersagen wenn tatsächlich eine
gefährdung für die öffentliche
sicherheit besteht das nicht ausreicht
sagt unser verfassungsrechtler ist
reicht nicht einfach allgemein auf eine
auf einer infektionsgeschehen zu
verweisen denn nach artikel 8 absatz 1
des grundgesetzes haben alle deutschen
das recht sich ohne anmeldung friedlich
und ohne waffen zu versammeln
auf den seiten des
bundesinnenministeriums kann man sogar
noch konkreter nachlesen die sagen ganz
ausdrücklich dieses grundrecht
ermöglicht es allen bürgern sich aktiv
am politischen meinungs- und
willensbildung des prozess zu beteiligen
insofern braucht es dann eben sehr
konkrete anhaltspunkte auch im vorfeld
einer demonstration zum beispiel das in
irgendeiner weise dort ein
gefährdungspotenzial besteht und nicht
eine ein allgemeines wir schränken aber
einfach irgendwie beschränken einfach
irgendwie ein als gefährdungspotenzial
wird ja auch oft angebracht ja wir
wissen nicht ob wirklich die abstände ob
die massen kriegt eingehalten wird ist
das ausreichend also du hast ja auch mit
verfassungsrechtlern gesprochen die
melden da ja auch zweifel an es muss ja
wirklich ein konkreter irgend einen
konkreten hinweis geben und die sorge ob
die abstände abgehalten werden dass da
wirklich aus das kann man ja mitunter
herleiten sozusagen daraus auf wie eine
solche demo vielleicht angemeldet ist
wenn das natürlich sozusagen
masken gegner sind oder so und gegner
sämtlicher corona maßnahmen kann man
davon ausgehen dass die diese maßnahmen
tatsächlich auch nicht ernst nehmen aber
mütter die jetzt gegen schulschließungen
demonstrieren die sogar vorhersagen wir
achten auf die maßnahmen wir haben
masken dabei auch das ist ja ersichtlich
die kann man dann nicht einfach mit
hinblick auf auf so ein so solche bringt
dann einschränken schauen wir einmal
drauf sebastian auf fünf besonders harte
besonders umstrittene
freiheitseinschränkung nach zwei jahren
corona krise also über diese demo verbot
haben wir gerade gesprochen ja auch noch
unter freiem himmel verhängt werden
zweig an unis das ist das was unser
reporter charly walter da gerade aus
hamburg auch mitgebracht haben also
vorlesung seminare die für ungeimpfte
nicht mehr geöffnet sind auch das zu
recht hart umstritten dort auch in
hamburg kontakte sind das dass du gerade
angesprochen sebastian also keine
freunde treffen für jugendliche ab 14
jahren ja man sitzt mit denen in der
schulklasse zusammen aber dann nach dem
schulunterricht ist vorbei mit privaten
treffen sportverbot auch für kleinkinder
zumindest dann wenn die eltern eben
nicht geimpft sind zum beispiel kein
schwimmen dann für die kinder und das
ist noch ein beispiel aus sachsen
vielleicht sagst du dazu noch kurz was
sebastian dieser skilift sind also
überall drumherum ist es erlaubt ski zu
fahren aber in sachsen beispielsweise
große skigebiet dort jens weißflog weiß
bescheid steht der skilift still ja da
muss ein schiff der siebten draußen ja
wer beim skifahren bin ich unter freiem
himmel und wir wissen die
ansteckungsgefahr ist unter freiem
himmel besonders gering wenn das was im
nachbarort auf der tschechischen seite
dann erlaubt ist das ist dann bei uns
höchstwahrscheinlich eigentlich auch
nicht falsch insofern hatte ich auch
diese maßnahme für sehr sehr fragwürdig
warum entscheidet man sich dafür was es
die große argumentation dahinter also
wir sehen ja auch viele andere länder
die sich bemühen kompromisse auch wir
hoffentlich jetzt am kommenden freitag
wird zumindest mal um die quarantäne
regeln geht aber warum halten wir immer
weiter in diesen so strengen regeln fest
ich glaube da muss man schauen auf den
beginn der pandemie also nochmal so
februar märz 2020 als das alles losging
da waren wir sogar später dran als
unsere nachbarn als es darum gegen
maßnahmen einzuführen da hatten wir zum
beispiel an flughäfen im ausland in
spanien beispielsweise längst bestimmte
corona kontrollen abstands maßnahmen
also und bei uns hatte man den eindruck
als hätten wir von der ganzen pandemie
noch überhaupt nichts mitbekommen hier
in berlin am flughafen beispielsweise
das hat mich seinerzeit sehr gewundert
und jetzt sind wir aber politisch in
einem modus wo man sagt also da kennt er
den schönen satz wenn ich nur ein hammer
arbeitsinstrument sieht alles aus wie
nagel also immer schön irgendwo
infektionsgeschehen darauf mit dem
hammer und dann diese regel und da das
und wenn hier ungeimpfte und soundso
viele personen viele menschen wissen ja
auch gar nicht mehr wie die regeln
konkret sind weil man sich das ja kaum
merken kann also ich zum beispiel
versuche mich vernünftig zu verhalten
aber ich weiß teilweise gar nicht beim
einzelnen weiß ich das ja auch ständig
verändert was die konkrete regel ist ich
nur sagen ich freue mich übrigens euch
heute hier wieder zu sehen denn ich war
selbst betroffen von einer sinnlos regel
wo mir auch völlig klar war während ich
sie befolgt hat wie sinnlos sind
guardian ich habe die vergangenen zehn
tagen in corona quarantäne verbringen
müssen warum weil ich kontakt hatte zu
einer person die ausgerechnet mit der
omicron variante infizierte was negativ
getestet waren und bahrain mal negativ
schnell getestet ich hatte zwei negative
pcr test sogar aber man konnte sich eben
nicht frei testen das ist aber eine
regel die ist schon eigentlich vier
wochen alt da dachte man umgekommen ist
neuer das ist vielleicht besonders
gefährlich jetzt wissen wir es ist
eigentlich ansteckende aber der verlauf
ist nicht so schlimmer kommen wir später
noch mal drauf auch auf die quarantäne
regeln die hoffentlich wahrscheinlich
dann am freitag geändert werden in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundesregierung aber schön dass du
wieder da bist sebastian vielen dank an
unseren bild reporter der mit uns
spricht über die freiheitseinschränkung
nach zwei jahren corona wie sehr fühlen
sie sich eigentlich noch eingeschränkt
durch diese freiheitseinschränkung
unsere bild reporterin julia ostner hat
sie gefragt
[Musik]
wir sind hier heute in celle in der
altstadt mitten in niedersachsen und wir
fragen die leute heute führt ihr euch
eingeschränkt durch die korona maßnahmen
ja oder nein
ja natürlich inwiefern haben man kann
seine jugend nicht mehr ausleben man
kann nicht mehr feiern gehen freunden
was essen gehen draußen das ist alles
eingeschränkt und die die nicht geimpft
sind die kann halt nicht mitkommen ja
eigentlich so in den restaurants jetzt
mit getestet wie bin gepustet jetzt und
finde ich ein bisschen blöd fühlst du
dich eingeschränkt in meiner freiheit so
ein bisschen ja so ein bisschen weil man
kann nicht mal so viele freunde treffen
und so alles und ja man ist ja noch
schon die meiste zeit zu hause ja
natürlich ein bisschen aber nicht so
heftig ich bin rentner ich mache
radsport und
was natürlich schockierend war der
lockdown der erste sorge habe ich schon
runter das erinnert mich irgendwie an
krieg oder sogar sehr als die ganze
innenstadt auf mal leer war ja klar ich
meine man kann halt nicht mehr einfach
so überall einkaufen gehen man braucht
teilweise tests nachweise und so weiter
und sofort klar dass man irgendwie
eingeschränkt
geringfügig muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
weil wir das gar nicht jetzt so stark
empfinden dass wir zu hause sind das war
vorher auch wenn man freunde treffen
will kann man sie ja noch treffen
allerdings
allerdings in michael
man kann ja viele örtlichkeiten zu sagen
gar nicht mehr besuchen also als
ungeimpfte sowieso nicht und wenn sie
geimpft sind müssen ja auch zunehmend
sich testen lassen das kann man sagen
okay ist auch nochmal mit aber es ist
natürlich sehr aufwendig nicht ich finde
sich durch die korona maßnahme in ihrer
in ihrer freiheit eingeschränkt ja in
gefahr
alleine das mit den masken laufen geht
mir mittlerweile so oft größe wir haben
ja auch ehrlich gesagt